In order to grow tiamut needs vast
amounts of energy from intelligent life
global earthquake swept nation states across
the world many have speculated its connection
with the uh reading on those tremors it was a
mild subduction under the african plate do we
have a visual how are we handling it nat it's
an earthquake under the ocean we handle it by
not handling it welcome back everyone this is
my video for the big black panther 2 easter egg
in the eternals movie and then finally paying
off that big atlantis namor easter egg from way
back in avengers endgame so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos also explain
what's going on with the new black panther because
we did get a preview for a lot of the roster
that's going to be showing up during avengers
5 and the later marvel movies but during avengers
end game we all saw black widow and okoye talking
about an underwater earthquake happening under the
african plate what that means is that there was
an earthquake around africa that extended into the
pacific the indian ocean the atlantic ocean on the
other side this whole area around africa and at
the time during the five year time jump before the
blip okoye claimed that because the worst of the
damage the most severe damage was underneath the
ocean wakanda wasn't going to do anything about it
they weren't going to look into it they were just
going to ignore it and move on because clearly
they don't think that anybody lives underneath
the ocean we know that's not true because we know
atlantis is under the ocean neymar and his people
live there but this was all before the avengers
reassemble the time heist mission the blip what
they just did in the eternals movie as you all
saw is they explained that after the blip brought
everyone back it increased earth's population
enough to give tiamut enough cosmic energy that he
finished developing and emerged from earth's
core thus they called it the emergence during
the movie a new celestial being born they also
explained that had thanos not snapped half of
all life during avengers infinity war teemit would
have originally emerged in the same time frame so
i did a video a little while ago about how thanos
technically saved the avengers from the celestials
by snapping half of all life because he basically
hit a giant pause button on the emergence
but during the eternals movie when they say the
emergence is happening in seven days you have to
remember the timeline that's not seven days after
avengers end game they actually confirmed that the
eternals movie is taking place around the same
time as spider-man far from home which is eight
months after avengers end game so originally had
thanos not snapped everyone in avengers infinity
war about eight months after infinity war tiamut
would have emerged and destroyed the entire planet
and as you probably guessed just connecting
the dots here the minor earthquakes during that
five year time jump that a koi and black widow
were talking about were actually teemit getting
closer to the point of emergence still a ways off
like he's slowly hitting a stage of development
where his celestial mind begins to awaken and he
moves around just a little bit like a baby who's
still not fully developed like not even close to
being born but his body is capable of kicking and
moving around a little inside its mother's womb
and after everyone comes back with the blip the
small earthquakes turn into much much larger
earthquakes that they feel all over the planet
like the baby is telling us it's time for the
birth he's coming so that's why during the five
year time jump even though tiamut wasn't close to
emerging he was still at a stage of development
where he could kind of automatically just shuffle
around just a little bit inside earth's core
causing big tremors all over the place they've
already confirmed that namor and the atlanteans
are going to be antagonists during black panther
2 they may or may not be the main villains there
might be some other secret villain pulling the
strings manipulating both sides the wakandans
black panther characters as well as the atlanteans
and namor but we know namor is in the movie and
even before they confirmed what was causing
the underwater earthquakes all around africa
the writers of avengers endgame claimed they
included that easter egg with the idea that
it was broad enough that marvel and kevin feige
could just use it in any future movie they wanted
to to drive plot but they implied that yes it
was meant to be a name or atlantis reference
during the iron man 2 post-credits scene nick
fury's map lists a bunch of points of interest
that shield has all over the world one of them
is off the eastern coast of africa here it's
meant to be atlantis so either nick fury and
shield knew atlantis existed at this point
or they just know that something weird is
here and haven't gotten past the defensive
cloaking technology that atlantis uses to hide
itself atlantis uses a combination of magic and
science because just like the wakandans atlantis
is an ancient city that's had thousands of years
longer than the rest of the world to develop
itself so atlantis is meant to be on par with
wakandan tech even though atlantis doesn't have
vibranium so everyone just assumed that they'd
eventually pay off the underwater earthquake and
name war stuff during black panther 2 and now what
the eternals movie has done is just explained the
why of it all what's going on with the underwater
earthquakes a metaphorically tiny easter egg about
something really huge that just happened and now
in present day before the events of black panther
2 implying that black panther 2 is going to be
happening after the events of the eternals movie
and after the events of spider-man no way home
teemit partially emerged inside the indian ocean
here on the other side of africa from atlantis
but he's so large he's so massive like you look
at the scale here when he burst out during this
montage like this is what he looks like if
he would have fully come out him just coming
out a little and turning to stone probably killed
almost all life in this part of the ocean and this
part of the planet into the pacific it would have
caused massive tidal waves like massive tsunamis
on every continent around him in this big circle
radius any landmass that's nearby so anyone living
nearby to this area just experienced a cataclysmic
natural disaster that they'll have to address
in one of the movies at some point there really
weren't any references to it during spider-man
no way home which was kind of disappointing i was
hoping for some background easter egg like j jonah
jameson news broadcast about big earthquakes and
a giant stone celestial emerging on the other side
of the planet but all the secondary earthquake
damage would have also extended around the rest
of the world to a lesser degree like tiamut coming
out caused earthquakes everywhere spider-man would
have felt them with his spidey sense and then
literally the ground beneath him in new york city
would have shaken so the namor black panther ii
theory is that the original earthquakes underwater
during the five-year time jump did severe damage
to atlantis and a bunch of his people died
they would have known that wakanda was capable of
giving them aid but chose to ignore them and taken
that as a big slight then again in present day
during the emergence things only got worse for
them more damage more atlanteans dying and even
if you're not a marine biologist or anything like
that anybody could tell you that a giant stone
celestial causing tsunamis everywhere would have
caused cataclysmic damage to the ecosystem of all
of earth's oceans killing a bunch of aquatic life
all over the planet so if neymar was already
pissed about wakanda not helping them a couple
years ago you have to imagine his rage when a
ton of ocean life dies during the eternals movie
press f to pay respects to earth's oceans so early
theory is what they might wind up doing in black
panther 2 is creating a situation where neymar
and the atlanteans believe wakanda are partially
responsible or they just refuse to help again and
that's what causes them to declare all-out war
against wakanda and kill t'challa black panther
they have to explain his death during the movie
it has to make sense in the most logical way to
do that and also make namor feel like a threat
is to have him be the one to kill t'challa they
have a long time bitter rivalry in the comics
so it makes sense and i know a lot of you are
asking now what's going on with the new black
panther who's gonna take the mantle from t'challa
and become the next black panther they're still in
the middle of finishing filming on black panther
2 but reportedly winston duke who plays him baku
just signed a brand new special quote-unquote
contract to have a much much bigger role in the
future of the marvel movies heading into marvel
phase 4 marvel phase 5 and beyond so the current
rumor is that m'baku will become the next black
panther and there was also a rumor you may have
heard about a while ago and i've talked about
this in a previous video that they're going to
say that nakia and t'challa had a child together
at some point between avengers infinity war and
when they're going to say that he dies during the
events of the black panther 2 movie and eventually
that child will take the mantle of black panther
and become king of wakanda when he's old enough
but he's still supposed to be a child during the
events of black panther 2 so m'baku is sort of
going to be the proxy black panther until he's
old enough to take the mantle from him i think
the reason why marvel might decide m'baku would
be the person to take the mantle is because he is
like the next best candidate that they had inside
the country because he almost beat t'challa during
their first challenge and then they went to m'baku
to get help with t'challa when he was trying to
defeat killmonger towards the end of the film and
during avengers infinity war m'baku already showed
that he was a big team player for those of you
asking about them bringing killmonger back because
i know there were a lot of people that were like
why don't they just bring in multiverse killmonger
and have him be black panther michael b jordan
has basically said in so many words that he is
probably coming back like he's tried to not give
spoilers away but i think it's pretty clear that
he's coming back but the rumor is that he's not
coming back as multiverse killmonger he's actually
coming back as the original killmonger who died
and he's gonna be force ghost killmonger from the
ancestral plane and he'll be giving advice to
the new black panther m'baku and also probably
t'challa's son so yes killmonger is coming back
for those of you that wanted him to come back but
not quite in the way that people were expecting
there's a whole subplot with mit riri williams
so that could have something to do with what's
going on with whatever the actual villain in
black panther 2 is doing like i don't think that
namor is going to get involved with riri williams
in mit and that seems like it's going to be a big
plot point during the film so the iron man armor
war series is probably connected to the iron heart
series is probably connected to what's happening
in black panther 2 and the armor war series is
all about some evil force trying to gain control
of all of iron man's technology but if there are
any other black panther 2 easter eggs that you
spotted during the eternals movie that i didn't
talk about during this video just write them below
in the comments and i will do more videos for
black panther 2 when we get some more footage
from the film the movie's coming out in november
so i'm expecting we'll probably get our first
trailer when they get ready to release thor
love and thunder maybe a little bit before that
while you wait for everything everyone click here
for my brand new marvel moon night trailer video
and click here for that eternals deleted scene
with kit harington's black knight character
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!